tuer son son ennemi c'est moins grave
que tuer son enfant je l'ai dit au
tribunal l'Holocauste actuel est plus
grave plus étendu plus terrible que on
parle jamais jamais jamais jamais un
holocauste mque un
autre ils vont de l'avant pour que la
loi fasse machine arrière pour eux
l'avortement est un crime comme les
autre la femme n'est que le réceptacle
d'une vie qui vient de Dieu et ce de la
conception
enfant en tête il marche pour le
mouvement charismatique traditionnaliste
Renaissance
catholique beaucoup milit dans une des
40 associations antiavortement française
dont une qu sont très
[Musique]
actives
Milie hospalier 18 ans après sa
légalisation et 11 ans après son
remboursement l'avortement est toujours
un sujet tabou dont personne n'aime
parler symbole de liberté pour beaucoup
crime organisé pour quelquesuns il
touche les corps les consciences les
convenances les
croyances il préfère l'Esprit Saint aux
esprits libre et mélange volonti
spirituel et
Politi aussi avec les hommes politiques
députés ou autres et n'hésitons pas à
renvoyer dans leur foyer quel que soit
leur parti du reste tous ces
exterminateurs de notre nation même
s'ils assistent à la messe le dimanche
accompagn des caméras de la
télévision laocpa association pour
l'objection de conscience à toute
participation à l'avortement incite ses
adhérents à acheter les actions du
laboratoire russellf qui fabrique la
pilule abortive elle tient également un
fichier appelé Spartacus sur les hommes
politiques français nous n'avons pas été
autorisé à filmer sa banque de données
situé à Besançon Micheline rose est
membre de la OCPA mais aussi de la Trêve
de Dieu et de SOS tout
[Musique]
petit chaque jour dans son modeste de
pièces elle pris la Vierge pour qu'elle
fasse cesser
l'avortement uvre de
Satan est un menteur et justement dans
le problème de l'avortement il y a il y
a un mensonge que ce soit à leur insu ou
non les gens cachent la vérité parce que
ça les dérange et qu'en fait c'est bien
commode après tout maintenant on cherche
le confort si on a un enfant qui arrive
et ça j'incrimine un petit peu la pilule
vous me direz que j'ai pas beaucoup de
mérite à mon âge et c'est c'est ce qu'on
me dit c'est vrai mais je crois que tout
se tient comme le pape on a on programme
sa vie on prend la pilule et puis il y a
l'accident ah ben non alors là je j'en
veux
pas Paris 7e arrondissement soirée de
sensibilisation de la Trêve de Dieu
thème du jour les opérations commando
x préfère parler d'opération sauvetage
mot feut trit pour Opération parfois
plus
musclé alors on va jusqu'au bloc où sont
les avortements et on se sert de notre
propre record comme d'un rempas la
plupart viennent pour la première fois
sur les conseils d'un ami ou après avoir
reçu un tracte dans leur paroisse ou
dans leur
école face à eux Marie liery professeur
de physique et leader d'un groupe
d'action pas une fois elle n'emploie le
mot de fettus ou d'embryon préférant
parler de bébé ou d'enfant donc tous les
hommes sont égau en droit et dignité
l'enfant avant la naissance est un homme
à partentière fait bien partie de notre
humanité
ils ne seront pas venus pour rien la
lumière les images qu'ils vont voir ils
ne les oublieront
pas film américain boucherie vidéo pour
motiver les futurs
[Musique]
sauveteurs ces images nous avons demandé
au professeur rou embryologue de les
regarder une première réaction
docteur bien il y a là un choix d'image
qui est destiné à être particulièrement
horrifiant là on s'est livré à une
reconstitution très très macabre dans le
but précisément de de frapper les les
spectateurs mais c'est vrai que c'est
c'est ce que l'on peut voir jusqu'à
euh jusqu'à 10 semaines l'embrion est en
cours de formation après 10 semaines ça
devient un fettus mais à 10 semaines il
mesure 3 cm et on peut dire que tous ces
organes sont en place euh ce qui euh ces
organes sont en place ça ne veut pas
dire que qu'il soi fonctionnel il y aura
encore toute une très longue période 7
mois qui lui reste pour qu'il assure sa
croissance
euh la différenciation cellulaire au
sein de ces organes et la
différenciation fonctionnelle au sein de
ces organes également donc on peut dire
que jusque pendant les la période légale
de l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse il n'y a pas de fonction des
organes sensoriels ni de fonction
cérébral qui permettent un niveau de
conscience de
l'embryon certaines images sont assez
assez confuses elles sont seulement
horrible mais assez confuse on peut pas
bon là je pense qu'il s'agit d' d'un
fétus qui a été évacué en dehors des
au-delà des dé laai de l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse et puis
la tête horrible qu'on vient à rajouter
là me paraît être un un montage assez
grossier savoir qui demain serait prêt à
participer à un
sauvetage est-ce que la Trêve de Dieu
protège les gens qui se mettent dans
l'illégalité en luttant contre
l'avortement et si oui comment en en
trois mots ce sont des gens qui ne se
mettent pas dans l'illégalité en ce sens
que cette loi estique
par conséquent la Trêve de Dieu les
défend en effet
puisque c'est injuste les défend comment
les défend juridiquement c'estàdire
s'occupe de de de contacter des avocats
de d'organiser le procès de de suivre
toute l'affaire devant les
tribunaux y compris
financièrement jusqu'à la loi Neyer oui
mais à partir de la loi neyerz non
c'està-dire que les personnes seront à
même demain de de de payer elles-même en
fait le le les 2 mois 2 ans de prison
les 2000 francs à 30000 francs d'amende
18 novembre 93 la Trêve de Dieu envahi
l'hôpital bretonau de tour 29 mai 92
même scénario à Bordeaux et ici le 5 mai
92 visite surprise au centre IVG de peau
deux ou trois personnes consultent les
dossiers médicaux pendant que les
autres deux personnes se sont enchaînées
avec des carcans de moto à cette table
de gynéco l'un d'un côté l'autre de
l'autre une autre personne s'est
enchaînée au lavabo et tout le monde a
fait un sitating en se tenant par les
bras ils ont tapissé tout le sol de la
salle déstérilisation bride lavabo
facture avancée par l'hôpital 70000
francs ce tracte a été déposé dans la
boîte au lettres d'un médecin de peau
rendez-vous chez Claire Fontana
présidente fondatrice de la Trêve de
Dieu enceinte de son 8e enfant elle nous
déclare être contre l'avortement dans
tous les cas y compris le viol je plaide
la cause de l'enfant qui est indépendant
du malheur qui est arrivé à à cette
femme hein il y a une victime une
première victime la femme éventuellement
de cette de ce crime il peut résulter un
autre enfant enfin une autre victime un
enfant mais est-ce que au premier crime
la mère va ajouter un deuxème crime
est-ce que le crime qu'elle a
subi elle va le transformer en crime
qu'elle commettra et puis attendez moi
je suis d'accord pour
l'avortement dans Ça c'est une première
je suis d'accord à condition que d'abord
il ait la peine de mort pour le
violeur depuis peu claire Fontana a
passé la main à Thierry leofèvre nouveau
président de la trêve deodieu milite
également dans l'association dissidente
protestante voyage beaucoup en Europe
très proche des MVS améain est-ce qu'il
y a une
Internationale des mouvements
anti-avortement est-ce que vous vous
voyez entre européen entre Français et
Américains ça dépend c'est pas quelque
chose de très organisé c'est quelque
chose qui se fait à
l'occasion tout dépend de l'opportunité
de la
circonstance beaucoup de choses se font
comme
cela il faut que tout le monde sache que
R dépend d'un groupe allemand qui
s'appelle h est l'héritier spirituel et
financier de Lig farb qui était cette ce
cartel immonde qui a fourni le gaz
Ciclon B au naz pendant la dernière
guerre là vous trouvez pas que vous
allez un petit peu loin ah non non pas
du tout c'est vrai c'est vrai je tout
les documents si vous voulez ça veut
dire que le génocide allemand et
l'avortement on peut mettre en terme
d'équation mathématique signe égal il y
a une équivalence oui effectivement
oui de l'avortement est encore plus
grave dans la mesure où la quantité de
personnes touché plus importantes encore
on en est de 25 millions par an sur la
terre actuellement lui aussi il était à
la marche de renaissance catholique
docteur zavieror médecin en embryologie
professeur d'université président de SOS
ToutPtit association qui n'a jamais
déposé ses
statut
[Musique]
il nous donne rendez-vous à 7h du matin
dans un petit village de la
Mayenne dernier briefing par le
responsable local et direction l'hôpital
de la
Val c'est la deuxè fois que
l'association du docteur d'or s'en prend
à cet
[Musique]
hôpital surprise nous y retrouvons
Madame
Rose
maintenant et à l'heure de
not sainte Marie Mère de Dieu priez pour
nousvcheurs maintenant àheure
de les femmes venu consulter attendront
les infirmières ont fermé toutes les
portes à
clés 10 minutes plus tard arrivée de la
police et du directeur de l'hôpital
prier souci
évacu notre équipe de
tournage en 2 ans 40 opération commando
contre cliniques et
hôpitaux il se disait photographe pour
un journal local en fouillant ses
papiers la police découvre qu'il est
surtout proche de
l'association sorti par la petite porte
de
l'ascenseur dehors une deè équipe de
faire publicité à l'établissement mais à
7 he matinale les visiteurs sont encore
rares sorti par la grande porte et sous
les applaudissements des fidèles pour le
docteur
d'or police compréhensive envahisseur
souriant nous ne sommes pas d notre
caméra a considérablement calmé le jeu
mais le 21 avril 92 à
colombe il n'y avait pas de
journaliste
[Musique]
malheureusement ces commandos qui depuis
bientôt 3 ans finalement interviennent
dans les centres particulier au centre
de colombe exerce une pression sur le
personnel paramédical et sur les
médecins il y en a un qui a tordu le
bras de la l'infirmière
responsable ils ont agressé les f
F puisque en le disant quoi en leur
disant qu'elles étaient des
assassins nous bloqué ils nous
empêchaient de rentrer dans les salles
d'intervention ils empêchaient les
femmes de se présenter là où il fallait
pour obtenir leurs
IVG ce qu'il faut savoir aussi c'est
qu'en dehors de ça il y a de multiples
coups de téléphone genre coup de
téléphone anonyme où on nous traite
d'assassin et cetera et
cetera je crois que ça c'est indéniable
les conditions de travail ont changé
nous nous méfions nous faisons plus
attention je crois que c'est une
pression supplémentaire qui
viseon concl qui vise diminuer
l'acibilité des
PA les Nouaux crois de l'avortj gagné
une
Bata de plus en plus Malu relve médic
Inc financ
éigma 26 de sur le papier en réalité de
plus en plus de Français reprennent le
chemin de l'étranger comme autrefois
Jean-Paul II en présence du frère Marx
leader des anti-avortements américains
vous faites le travail le plus important
sur terre le Pape aradom a comparé le
cimetière des Juifs au cimetière de
l'avortement à votre avis a-t-il fait
une gaffe ou a-t-il eu raison je ne peux
pas me permettre de de de juger le
Saint-Père dans dans quand il a dit ce
qu'il a dit euh ce qu'il a dit était
parce qu'il a repris très très la
terminologie des mouvements
anti-avortement américains et français
oui euh
il n'a pas dit que ça heureusement et je
crois que même là-dessus votre point de
vue mais vous ne voulez pas me faire
dire le contraire de ce qu'a dit le le
pape Jean-Paul
II je je je je pense que il y a de temps
en temps une parole forte à dire et
certaines comparaisons sont parlantes
voici comment l'Association catholique
des infirmières et des médecins décrit
la pilule RU 486 R2 ru est la 18e lettre
de l'alphabet 3 x 6 18 666 le chiffre de
la bête RU 486 est alors l'agent le plus
redoutable de
Satan par
deationie d'AV j'en a un pas envieen
avoir un j'en a pas il va pas me cacher
ma vie il va pas mourir mais envie
baiser envie
baiser
guerre la vie cellulaire Estelle
synonyme de vie humaine et quand
commence l'être
humain à la première cellule parce que
tout le message génétique est imprimé à
2 mois parce que tous les organes sont
en place à 7 mois parce que le cervelet
atteint sa configuration finale à la
naissance parce que l'enfant pose les
pieds sur terre qui faut-il favoriser la
qualité de la vie de la mer ou l'embon
qui a un court passé etuttre un long
avenir pour le professeur le jeune
généticien mondialement connu membre de
l'Académie pontificale scientifique la
réponse est simple monsieur si par
malheur ce qu'à Dieu ne plaise et ça ne
se produira pas mais si par malheur
l'Église catholique disait que
l'avortement est légitime parce que ça
ne tue personne je ne ferai plus partie
de l'église catholique pour des raisons
scientifiques mais le professeur le
jeune n'est pas seulement un des
conseillers du pape il est également un
des 59 experts du mouvement
anti-avortement américain human life
international autre médecins autre point
de vue des femmes Joë Koffman gyécologue
en reçoit toute la journée depuis les
années 70 elle se bat au côté du
planning familial pour que cesse
avortement clandestin et grossesse
détresse nous on travaille beaucoup
autour de ce fameux statut de l'embryon
puisque je travaille Antoine beccler qui
est une maternité on fait aussi beaucoup
de faéonation une VI trop notre idée à
tous sur le plan éthique c'est que
l'enfant peut pas exister sans le désir
s'il y a pas un désir d'un coup couple
qui veut un enfant l'enfant il existe
pas il a pas sa place il aura pas sa
place dans ce couple il aura pas sa
place dans le monde il sera malheureux
et qu'un enfant sans désir des parents
c'est pas un
enfant tribunal de bobignny après
l'invasion de la clinique de la Mairie
des Lilas à Paris un groupe
d'infirmières porte plainte zaviador est
poursuivi pour cou et blessures ce
jour-là nous allons entendre des propos
qui reviendront comme un like motif je
l'ai dit au tribunal tu es son son
ennemi c'est moins grave que tuer son
enfant je l'ai dit au tribunal
l'Holocauste actuel est plus grave plus
étendu plus terrible que le on en parle
jamais jamais jamais jamais un
holocauste masque un autre
enfin c'est une chose tellement grave
nous nous ne pouvons pas tant qu'il y
aura un avortement permis en France pas
de problème l'Holocauste c'est
l'Holocauste et on doit le garder là où
où les choses se sont vraiment passées
pendant la dernière guerre on n pas le
droit de prendre ce mot-là n'importe
comment je vous ai déjà dit je vous ai
déjà dit que j'entends l'Esprit Saint
parler par votre
bouche mais j'aimerais bien que ce soit
l'Esprit Saint
vraiment quand nous aidons les femmes à
interrompre une grossesse nous pensons
simplement c'est c'est simplement un
début un potentiel de vie alors que vous
vous dites déjà que c'est un enfant et
on na jamais vu une femme qui avait
avorté dire où est mon enfant où est mon
bébé c'est pas vrai comme ça fait gentil
ça fa SOS tout petit comme on a envie de
les aider ces gens-là ces gensl comment
ils pratiqueent qu'est-ce qu'ils
viennent faire dans les maternités
qu'est-ce qu'ils viennent faire chez les
femmes fragilisées à ce moment-là
qu'est-ce qu'ils viennent demander aux
femmes est-ce qu'ils viennent parler
avec les femmes non ils viennent
simplement brandir des chapelet brandir
des des slogans venir perturber
complètement l'équilibre qu'on essaie de
donner aux femmes dans une maternité où
il y a des femmes qui accouchent il y a
des femmes qui viennent renoncer à une
grossesse verdict du tribunal 12000
francs d'amende mais ce que nous avions
entendu nétait rien à côté de ce que
nous Allion entendre çaêre suffrage
universel çaêtre la volonté générale je
n'accepte pas le décret de la volonté
générale pour moi c'est nul et nonenu la
volonté générale ne m'intéresse que dans
la mesure où elle s'inscrit dans la
volonté divine je dirais Hitler était un
petit enfant à côté de notre de nos
hommes Politi actuellement puisque nous
avons on peut compter 7 millions de
morts encore une fois Hitler a fait
moins de mort que nous par jour nous
sommes en pleine paix Hitler a fait
certain de mort que nous l' faisons dans
le journal d'extrême droite présent le
docteur dor déclare la femme c'est
l'enfant qui tient la femme tient
l'enfant et la civilisation au schwiz
tour pour tout le monde c'est le lieu
symbole du génocide donc quoi de plus
facile à à à penser d'aller là-bas pour
prier contre le nouveau génocide il
s'appelle
wmeling il est le secrétaire général de
l'Union des nations européennes
catholiques et dirige 1700
militants aussi passionné que
travailleur monsieur ming est très fier
de sa dernière
campagne c'est une collecte qu'on a fait
dans toute l'Europe dans toutes les
langues de chaque pays là en russe en
allemand français pour signer une
feuille qui dit hautement que ces
personnes sont contre l'avortement dans
le quotidien d'extrême droite présent
monsieurmeling déclare nous allons
lancer dans plusieurs villes d'Europe un
enterrement solennel d'un embryon
avorté
le docteur tremblé président de la plus
vieille association française
anti-avortement laissez-les vivre pour
lui des natalités danger IVG les trois
mots sont liés ça va jusqu'au génocide
de l'Europe de l'Ouest qui est en cours
on m'a dit aussi que le docteur tremblé
serait récupéré par le Front
national vos rapport ave totalement est-
vous êtes membre du S que non je suis
pas membre bien sûr je pourrais l'tre
parce que ça pourrait tomber comme ça
mais je je ne sa pas dis
Paron sont vos rapports avec les partis
politiques aujourd'hui euh nous sommes
totalement indépendant curieux sur cette
plaquette du cnfe Cercle National des
femmes d'Europe le docteur tremblé est à
l'honneur Cercle National des femmes
d'Europe dirigé par le député Martine
leï2 proche de Jean-Marie Le Pen mars 91
20e anniversaire de laisser les vivre au
Palais des Congrès à Paris parmi les
membres
d'honneur anon Front National brunonich
Front National mariefance tibois Front
national Martine le Front
national sur cette vidéo de la Trêve de
Dieu concernant les préparatifs d'une
manifestation à la Défense à Paris une
parodie de drapeau
naz le logo du laboratoire russf a
remplacé la croix gamé la comparaison se
poursuit l'amalgame aussi depuis 3 ans
famet chercheuse à Paris 7 journaliste
travaille sur l'extrême droite en France
son chemin universitaire a croisé plus
d'une fois les mouvements
anti-avortement français pour elle
terminologie et imagerie sont
soigneusement choisies aux États-Unis il
y a eu un livre qui a été publié qui
s'appelle the abortion Holocaust today's
final solution qui fait un parallèle
constant entre ce qui s'est passé sous
le nazisme pour les Juifs uniquement
parce qu'il s'agit pas du tout de
relativiser les autres les autres mort
et aussi ce qui s'est passé au niveau
des enfants avortés enfin des enfants
des personnes qui considèrent comme des
enfants avortés critique de ce livre
dans le magazine français transv les
salles d'attente des avortoirs sont
fleurie et propre comme la garde arrivée
de dacho un livre de référence et
d'étude ce livre circule dans les
mouvements anti-avortement français oui
il est tout d'abord paru il a paru en
aux
États-Unis mais ensuite il a il a été
distribué assez assez largement mais aux
États-Unis il n'a pas eu beaucoup
beaucoup de succès c'est au moment où il
est arrivé en France beaucoup de de de
revu ont fait sa publicité notamment
transv qu'il a connu du succès parce
qu'il a justement rencontré ce désir de
banalisation des des antiavortements
Français Pierre Andr tagief directeur de
recherche au CNRS spécialiste de
l'extrême droite en France il dévoile
pour nous la face cachée du discours
antiivg si l'Holocauste est partout il
n'y a plus d'holocauste si les nazis
sont partout si les médecins les
infirmières et les maires en difficulté
qui demandent une IVG sont des nazis ou
des complices des nazis il y a plus de
nazisme les nazis finalement ressemblent
à des maères de famille qui pratiquent
l'IVG les intégristes antiavortement des
pseudodéfenseurs de la vie sont en fait
des ennemis de la modernité politique
elle devrait s'inquiéter tout de même de
cette nouvelle configuration entre euh
l'appel à l'ordre moral euh deuxièmement
euh des euh la
dénonciation euh xénophobe de
l'immigration àvasion parce que c'est
tout de même un élément de ce type de
discours il faut faire des enfants pour
éviter l'immigration invasion il faut
faire des des embryons de souches pour
éviter que des immigrés en face qui
soient radicalement étrangers et donc il
y a l'église me semble-t-il n'a pas pris
la mesure de cette nouvelle conjonction
entre une entre des courants d'extrême
droite entre des intégristes catholiques
qui se
réclam de bien sûr du Vatican et euh
d'un public plus large qui s'interroge
sur les nouvelles questions de
bioéthique tout à fait légitimement et
qui risque d'être séduit par ce discours
dogmatique derrière la défense de
l'embryon quelques nouveaux croisés
cachent une mission plus
sombre fort de leur vérité ils avancent
parmi les chrétiens nombreux qui se
posent des questions sur la vie ils
marchent pour leur combat pour leur foi
pour le pape pour la rechristianisation
de l'Europe et quelquesuns peu nombreux
mais actifs n'ont certainement pas
l'intention d'en rester
là
[Musique]